du spectacle à la base a été proposé par
une association qui s'appelle passion
croisé une pièce qui s'appelle le Stabat
Mater d'un compositeur qui s'appelle
Pergolèse le Stabat matter reprend la
mort du Christ l'idée de l'association
passion croisée c'était de rendre la
scène plus visuelle et donc de demander
aux danseurs incarnés le personnage du
Christ
alors Gilles il a pas transformé
l'église en cabaret il a fait un
spectacle avec effectivement des
éléments de modernité un danseur de pole
dance champion de France de pole dance
c'était pas vulgaire c'était un peu sexy
les menaces de mort c'est tout de toute
façon scandaleux mais là je suis
totalement du côté de ce pasteur les
menaces de mort sont
affrontements et incroyablement
[Musique]
décapités et la tête du prêtre coupée
pour avoir présenté toutes les clés de
notre sainte Église à un serpent dansant
ça on devient ça devient fou
tu vas mourir non mais
il est quand même bien sûr faut pas
cautionner menaces mais il est quand
même dans la provocation c'est pas du
tout l'endroit approprié pour faire ça
que ce soit une église catholique une
synagogue ou une mosquée on ne fait pas
d'une pole dance qui est une danse à
connotation sexuelle dans une église
donc moi je comprends que ça suscite des
réactions après évidemment les menaces
ont les cautionnent pas mais c'est quoi
les limites à ce moment-là c'est qu'on
peut on va faire quoi des strip-tease de
musique baroque et pourquoi provoquer
aux gens qu'on peut le dérailleurs ça
sert à rien
tu pensais que c'était des filles toi
regarde c'est un homme déjà pareil
d'accord
ça on comprend bien sûr
pourquoi on a Chloé Jésus faut pas qu'il
tourne tu vois comme ça tu vois
merci Jean-Marie
quand tu vois la photo tu vois l'église
avec quelqu'un qui fait des pole dance
devant même tu peux dire tous les
discours que tu veux c'est anachronique
il y a quelque chose qui est en décalage
total avec la foi qui ont beaucoup de
gens et je trouve voilà tu bois après
dire tu veux faire preuve de modernité
tu essayes de d'ouvrir de s'ouvrir aux
autres il y a plein d'endroits pour
s'ouvrir pas forcément dans une minute
on a acceptait pas une musique dite
baroque ou moderne parce qu'il y avait
des dents qui étaient qui étaient des
notes du diable donc il faut s'adapter
aussi avec le temps qui évolue là c'est
ce n'est pas un sacrilège le prêtre
c'est lui qui le met en place un
passeport
c'est lui qui le met en place c'est une
musique c'est une musique lyrique et
sacrée enfin il y a pas de musique là je
parle de lui l'image toi
tu dire ça montage ou c'est une peinture
moderne un peu subversive etc mais là
franchement non c'est pas torse
est-ce que c'est paroissiens ont été non
non
forcément dans une église là c'est la
représentation du Christ le Christ est
torse nu donc voilà il y a une espèce de
effectivement la barre de pole dance
représente la croix
engueuler mais pour une fois mais pour
une fois moi qui suis extrêmement
ouverte d'esprit alors là pour une fois
je trouve que c'est un peu une erreur
voilà on a quelques images de répétition
du spectacle avant que vous puissiez
voir à quoi cela ressemble vous allez
voir
puisqu'on a on a le pasteur nous a tout
dit derrière il a il a répondu dans
l'émission regardez
[Musique]
si
hop là
on a quand même beaucoup critiqué on le
rappelle Benjamin qui avait précédé
qu'une caméra au lieu d'un iPhone que
c'est différent
subjectif je suis désolé
je précise parce que je vais encore
avoir des menaces sur les réseaux
sociaux donc je précise comme le docteur
et je précise que oui j'accepterai aussi
que ça ait lieu parce que on me le
reproche à chaque fois dans une
synagogue ça me pose aucun problème
voilà donc parce que on me dit tout dur
toi tu parles pour les aider pour les
églises et dans les synagogues donc oui
ça me pose aucun problème dans une
synagogue voilà non mais là où il y a
une erreur pour moi c'est une erreur de
mise en scène le problème c'est la barre
c'est la barre de pole dance c'est ça
qui rapporte en fait aux filles un peu
sexy la cils etc s'il avait fait la même
chose je pense avec non mais tu sais
avec les bah non mais tu pouvais
remplacer peut-être la barre par les
espèces de de draps vous savez quand ils
font des numéros etc peut-être que ce
serait passé différemment la même chose
non mais voilà tu vois je pense que
c'est le problème de la barre de pole
dance que c'est rattaché au strip-tease
c'est tout c'est juste ça en fait parce
que le spectacle pour moi est pas genre
moi je félicite ce pasteur je le trouve
avant-gardiste je le trouve courageux je
le trouve audacieux je trouve que c'est
extraordinaire dans une époque qui est
autant rétrograde autant intolérante
d'oser faire un truc comme ça et vous
allez pas être plus réaliste que le roi
ou plus pasteuriste que le pasteur si
lui il a envie de faire ça je vois pas
pourquoi il aurait pas le droit de le
faire surtout que les fidèles sont
d'accord en fait c'est que de la
provogue et tout le monde s'en fout de
sa personne fait du Pole dance torse nu
enfin c'est il y a peu de gens qui le
font mais oui mais tout est artistique
aujourd'hui on se voilà ça fait du je
pense ça fait du mal à bouffer moi je je
suis pas dans une église et ça fait ça
fait plus de mal aux gens que ça non non
divertit est-ce que tu vas dans cette
paroisse non mais il y a des gens qui
vont qui n'ont pas envie de voir ça ils
sont choqués justement c'est ça en fait
c'est l'art de la provoc c'est faire
chier le monde pour faire chier le monde
personne n'a envie de voir ça les gars
il est soutenu par ces paroissiens tu
entends ça
puis choquer certaines personnes
c'est juste comprendre que ça puisse
spectacle puisse choquer parce que pour
beaucoup de personnes je pense que le
mot poètes renvoie à cabaret voir
strip-tease alors que ce n'est pas
forcément le cas puisque cela fait des
arts du cirque et c'est plutôt de la
danse mais c'est ça le problème le
problème c'est l'ignorance en fait des
gens et le problème c'est que
déjà il y a pas d'ouverture d'esprit
quand on parle de la religion tout le
monde est hyper optif fermé etc il faut
faire s'il faut faire ça
protestant mais aussi les catholiques
aussi les Juifs
on défend son église on défend sa
paroisse et on veut pas sortir du cadre
et et voilà et il a raison à un moment
donné on peut comprendre que ça puisse
gêner mais les gens ne savent pas ce que
c'est pour eux ils l'associent au
strip-tease alors que ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup réagir
certains responsables de la paroisse
était eux-mêmes un peu étonné regardez
oui c'est étonnant un certain nombre de
paroissiens notamment des responsables
de la paroisse ne savaient pas du tout
ce qu'est la pole dance c'est vrai
qu'ils ont été un peu étonnés des
affiches avec un danseur pas forcément
très habillé donc ils sont allés voir le
spectacle avec quelqu'un préhension mais
après le spectacle les réactions ont été
toutes différentes puisque les personnes
qui ont assisté à ces concerts ont été
surtout
émusateur trouve que Valérie Benaim
chevaux mouillé à des avis beaucoup plus
incessifs que le
qui est d'accord si vous voulez beaucoup
de gens qui réagissent s'il vous plaît
moi je suis totalement d'accord avec le
pasteur il faut quand même rappeler que
c'était à 17 pour ce spectacle de police
qui était à guichet fermé qui a fait un
triomphe d'ailleurs il y en aura
d'autres et heureusement et à ma
connaissance aucun des fidèles présents
ce soir-là n'a récriminé après tout le
monde a été séduit et attention là on
donne notre avis mais je rappelle quand
même qu'il est menacé de morts
ça dans une mosquée mais bien sûr et
bien sûr je t'enverrai ça quel est le
quel est le propriétaire les religions
elles sont strictes ne sont pas strictes
les religions elles sont belles elles
sont là pour défendre des valeurs et la
nudité et l'apologie
parce que c'est clairement sexuel c'est
de la promotions
de manière latine
hyper important et quand un homme est
menacé de décapitation il faut lui
apporter son soutien
contre les menaces
c'est moi je suis contre ce genre de
spectacle donc je vais évidemment passer
pour quelqu'un qui est pour les gens qui
veulent des capitaux c'est il y a il
peut y avoir peut-être un juste milieu
et Guillaume a dit exactement
quand ce sont des femmes qui font ça
évidemment tout le monde Glou c'est les
hommes sont excités comme là c'est de la
déconstruction c'est-à-dire c'est un
homme c'est pas un hasard parce que
cette cette
connu pour les tendances LGBT ils sont
dans ce combat
c'est simplement
on repousse les limites et et évidemment
comme il y a des imbéciles et même pire
que ça la font des menaces de mort on ne
peut plus rien dire moi ça me choque
j'ose le dire évidemment que pas une
seule seconde je pense à faire des
menaces mais on nous teste et on
repousse un petit peu et on va dans le
combat il a évoqué il a évoqué il y a
des milliers de salle de spectacles en
France on va pas me dire que c'est un
hasard s'il y a cette chorégraphie
tu es contente que soit la religion le
droit à la caricature et la religion
mais quel est le message
dans quel verset de la Bible on dit que
Jésus se frotter une barre de pole dance
il a également évoqué les menaces qu'il
avait reçu donc voilà suite à la
première représentation c'est ça qui est
dommage
des courriers de menaces ont été
découverts sous les portes de l'église
avec notamment un courrier manuscrit qui
disait simplement pas de musique pas de
danse dans l'église il était question de
décapiter les paroissiens il y avait
avec ce courrier un deuxième qui parlait
du pasteur qui a donné les clés de la
sainte Église ce serpent qui danse et là
il était question de décapiter le
pasteur
quelques jours après des flyers des
concerts ont été retrouvés sous la porte
de l'église avec des mots comme
blasphème ou encore à mort la question
je le rappelle c'est faut-il interdire
ce spectacle de pole dance dans une
église c'est ça la question oui ou non
ça n'a rien il faut l'interdire
Jean-Marie
moi je suis très respectueux des lieux
singes je reconnais Dieu je sens Dieu
tant dans une mosquée que dans une
église que dans une une église comme
celle-ci et ça me gêne de voir un mec
presque nu danser sur une barre qui
représente quand même le sexe quoi dans
le pole dance la barre quand c'est dansé
avec une fille on voit donc le sexe
là en l'occurrence
il tourne autour
alors Jean-Michel Sachs aussi oui ça me
choque parce que
avant que ça soit pole dance c'est un
art du cycle du cirque enfin un art de
cirque j'ai été dans 1000 siècles dans
ma vie j'en ai jamais vu j'ai été pas
mal le club de strip-tease à Paris j'ai
toujours vu des poils dance donc faut
pas essayer de dire non de dévoyer un
peu la polygale la poule dance c'est un
caractère sexuel ça c'est une
connotation sexuelle et si tu retires la
musique tu regardes la danse tu penses
pas la crucifer la crucifixion du Christ
une seule seconde je vois pas où il
allégorie je vois pas où est le voilà je
vois pas où est-ce que la crucifixion
là-dedans
je suis désolé
qui font des trucs comme ça
détourné ce truc là après moi pourquoi
je dis oui alors j'aime pas le terme
interdire le spectacle mais je pense que
les gens sont pas prêts quoi apparemment
les gens ne les remplir après avoir ce
genre de choses après mais les gens
là-bas étaient prêts les gens là-bas
étaient prêts faut-il risquer ce genre
de réaction je trouve que voilà il y a
une forme quand même de provocation moi
je personnellement je ne trouve pas mais
je comprends je comprends que ça puisse
choquer voilà donc normalement dans une
église de protestante il y a pas de
représentation du Christ la croix et
vide normalement moi ce qui me gêne
quand vous parlez de provocation on est
d'accord Daniel dit c'est dommage
quelques imbéciles attention des menaces
de mort c'est extrêmement grave il a
provoqué
de l'art dans une église et de l'art
dans votre vous êtes obtus Jean-Michel
par exemple c'est de l'art dans une
église
chorégraphie
la Provence
le goût le lieu c'est pas le lieu
le jeu des intérêts
justement le fait dans une église femme
non il faut
le faire s'il vous plaît alors le
pasteur est tout à fait prêt à discuter
avec les personnes qui n'apprécient pas
ce spectacle cependant il n'accepte pas
les menaces il a d'ailleurs porté
plainte regarde
que ce spectacle choc mais il y a
toujours moyen d'en parler de vive voix
ou j'ai eu des échanges de courrier ou
sur les réseaux sociaux mais je pense
que des menaces sont tout à fait
inadmissibles et je ne pouvais pas
laisser passer cela je suis donc passé
au commissariat pour porter plainte et
quand la deuxième série de tract est
arrivé je suis retourné au commissariat
alors tu vois regarde sur l'image on
voit un Christ sur la croix ce qui est
normalement n'est pas admis dans une
église protestante il y a pas de
représentation de crise dans une église
protestante il y a que la croix c'est il
y a pas le Christ cloué dessus là c'est
le cas sur l'hôtel on le voit mais
qu'est-ce que vous en tirez comme ça
c'est une association d'art du spectacle
qui avait
occupé avec l'accord du pasteur la salle
pour ça en quoi ça vous gêne quel est
votre nom curieux c'est que dans une
église protestante le le pasteur a sur
son hôtel un Christ cloué sur la croix
ça n'est pas normalement admis par
l'Église protestante c'est tout ce que
je dis alors on va voir ce qu'on pense
c'était les spectateurs s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
dans les églises 83% disent oui d'autres
spectacles du même si ils sont prévus
dans les prochains jours Monsieur le
Pasteur nous a expliqué pourquoi il est
important pour lui de ne pas les annuler
regarder
le spectacle parce que
nous pouvons pas nous arrêter à deux ou
trois personnes qui écrivent un courrier
de menace pour être plus rien faire et
ce serait vraiment jaillir une sorte de
dictature par par les menaces alors que
ils ont beaucoup plus sur la réflexion
alors oui non mais s'il aime les
spectacles de pole dance qu'il en fasse
mais ailleurs ce n'est pas le lieu on va
pas voir un spectacle de pole dance à
l'église comme on ne va pas voir une
messe dans un street club c'est
exactement la même chose donc pour moi
on est uniquement dans la provocation et
il ne veut rien faire à part tester les
limites et énerver les gens et les
mettre exactement pourquoi c'est
paroissiens sont allés et c'est parce
qu'on fait
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des gens qui
vont personne et encore une fois arrêtez
de faire les hypocrites là dessus vous
savez très bien dans une mosquée ou dans
ou dans une synagogue ça ne passerait
pas c'est tout mais alors pourquoi et
bah donc ça doit passer dans une église
parce que la religion c'est sacrée il
faut respecter la religion